All the tests we've done so far are called parametric tests. I just felt like
writing that in cursive. They test hypotheses and make assumptions about the
parameters of the population, mu and sigma. But what happens if we ask a
question or take a measurement using a scale that's not interval or ratio? For
example, what if I asked 100 people, Yes or No? Or what if I asked 100 men and
100 women if they prefer the beach or the mountains. We can't say something
like the average favorite vacation spot is the beach. Instead, we use
frequencies and proportions to describe these data. In this lesson, you're
going to learn hypothesis testing techniques that do not require parametric
information, like mean and standard deviation. These are called nonparametric
tests. I don't know why it's so fun to write parametric in cursive. I think
I'll just keep doing that. The nonparametric test you'll learn today is the
chi-squared test, where chi is another Greek symbol that looks like an x.